es ist noch so frisch die Entscheidung
über alle drei Atomkraftwerke nämlich
auch das Atomkraftwerke Niedersachsen
Emsland auch das soll also bis April bis
ins Frühjahr hinein nun laufen hat der
Kanzler heute einmal auf den Tisch
gehauen und hat das per äh Machtwort
sozusagen per Richtlinienkompetenz
entschieden das heißt die Grünen haben
ab jetzt da nichts mehr zu melden in
ihre Region der Kanzler zieht das mit
Ihnen durch nein die Grünen werden das
natürlich mittragen davon gehe ich mal
aus als staatsfragen eine Partei aber
klar ist natürlich dass er eine viel
früher laufen müssen denn wir haben ja
schon länger ein Problem nicht nur um
Gaspreis sondern auch im Strompreis und
das dass das jetzt so lange gedauert hat
ist eben auch an Herrn das mittragen da
müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz einhalten
glauben sie das auch Herr scheuer bisher
gibt es noch ganz wenige Reaktionen erst
von den Grünen das heißt der Schaeffler
sagt jetzt sie werden das mittragen die
haben am Wochenende nämlich das war
genau gestern und vorgestern das
Gegenteil auf ihrem Parteitag
beschlossen und diskutiert
euch das Wochenende an ich weiß nicht ob
jetzt die Grünen noch etwas
ausnüchternd unterwegs sind von diesem
Parteitag schaut euch die Reden an wo er
Habeck lange argumentiert hat dass der
weiterbetriebe im Emsland eben nicht gut
ist und jetzt ein paar Stunden später
kommt in Wirklichkeit die Ernüchterung
also wir werden sehen ich glaube
Donnerstag Entscheidung stehen im
Deutschen Bundestag stimmen Sie mit da
werde ich mal stimmt Moment Moment
wo sich jetzt der Schäffler so freut
über diese Entscheidung die ist nicht
nicht im Grundsatz nämlich die
nachhaltige denn
bis April also
sie hätten auch immer das Laufen bis
April ist jetzt natürlich wer Schäffler
muss das auch gut heißen natürlich auch
ein Teil Mini klein Erfolg für Christian
Lindner aber Fakt ist dass die die Krise
ja weit über den April geht das immer
wieder
ich sehe diesen diesen Vorschlag den
jetzt herr Scholz durchgedrückt hat mit
Richtlinienkompetenz nach ein paar
Stunden des grünen Parteitags für eben
zu kurz gesprochen
und ihre Fraktion wird nein sagen ja
scheuer der Scheuer mit seiner mit
seiner cdu/csu läuft lässt sich schön
auflaufen bzw die Grünen die kriegen sie
doch nie dazu dass die diesen macht der
Opposition auch an ihre Verantwortung
nicht also ich sag mal für die grüne ist
das natürlich ein großer Schritt aber
der reicht natürlich nicht aus natürlich
völlig klar aber das heißt sie brauchen
zum Regieren sie appellieren jetzt an
die cdu/cs
brauchen zum Regieren jetzt unbedingt
den
nach dieser Entscheidung sagen sie schon
das reicht nicht das sieht man den
Zustand der Koalition ist völlig klar
hätten wir Vorschlag von Friedrich Merz
aus dem März
umgesetzt dass wir Nord Stream ein
sofort abgeschaltet hätten dann hätten
wir schon im Sommer die
katastrophezition hat eine gewisse
Verantwortung in diesem Land gewisse
Dinge auch mit durchzusetzen und da
appelliere ich an der Union
beispielsweise wir haben
verteidigungsetagen Frau Engeln Käfer
jetzt haben wir dieses Machtwort und die
Grünen werden möglicherweise da nicht
zustimmen kann ja auch verstehen die
haben gerade auf ihren Parteitag das
Gegenteil beschlossen jetzt sagt der
Scheuer trägt er auch nicht mit dann
steht die FDP mit ihrem Kanzler alleine
und Sie verlieren die Abstimmung im
Bundestag also ich glaube wir sollten
hier ein bisschen abrüsten verbal denn
wir sind in das ganze Desaster alle
gemeinsam gekommen nicht denn wer hat
die Entscheidungen getroffen in der
Vergangenheit dass wir jetzt in dieser
Abhängigkeit sind ich glaube da können
wir uns alle an die eigene Nase fassen
und deshalb alle sage ich alle naja der
andere wenig ja also aber deshalb wäre
es jetzt wichtig dass wir das Dilemma
nicht weiter fortführen denn es geht ja
um die Menschen und es geht um die
Wirtschaft um beides und auch die
Wirtschaft hat ja Arbeitsplätze die
wiederum wichtig sind für die
Entwicklung unserer Wirtschaft und für
das was Menschen an Wohlstand oder eben
an Einkommen daraus ziehen und später
als Rente und deshalb dürfen wir das
nicht blockieren sondern da haben alle
die verantwortlich
ganz kurz ich war bei Stopp ich war bei
der moment mal
sie hat natürlich Recht alle haben den
Atomausstieg mit beschlossen egal in
welchen regierungskonstellationen waren
alle dafür Topmanager Gewerkschaftler
alle waren dafür so aber unser Thema ist
ja wir müssen jetzt in einer neuen Lage
Politik machen die neue Lage hat sich
mit dem 24 Februar verändert das ist der
entscheidend
ganz wichtigen Satz gesagt und der war
es geht doch hier um die Menschen es
geht um unseren Wohlstand und es geht um
unsere Wirtschaft Herr Lucke ist das
tatsächlich ihr Eindruck nach jetzt ja
bald irgendwie einem Jahr Regierung das
ist hier tatsächlich um die Menschen
geht um die Bürger geht um die
Wirtschaft geht es geht bei den Grünen
ja ganz offenbar um eine
parteitagsentscheidung um alte grünen
Biografie es geht darum hierbei Herrn
scheuer ob man das jetzt strategisch
damit trägt im Bundestag ja oder nein
aber
die Menschen und um den Wohlstand also
ich muss schon sagen mich hat das
bisschen konzentriert jetzt gerade
dieser Austausch hier weil ich denke
dieses kleinen kleinen was ich jetzt
hier am Tisch so abgespielt hat ja bei
einer solch existenziellen Krise wie wir
sie haben da habe ich wenig Verständnis
dafür und ehrlich gesagt ich verstehe
auch die Lesart nicht nicht so ganz die
von dieser Richtlinien Kompetenz
Entscheidung des des Bundeskanzlers dass
man jetzt sagt die die Grünen haben da
Federn gelassen also ich sehe es ehrlich
gesagt ganz ganz anders die Grünen haben
von Bank angesagt zwei Atomkraftwerke
sollen noch drei Monate laufen die FDP
hat gesagt drei Atomkraftwerke sollen
noch laufen aber bis 2024 jetzt sagt der
Bundeskanzler gutes sollen drei
Atomkraftwerke noch drei Monate laufen
also eigentlich ist das für die grüne
Sache war es nicht das zu akzeptieren
finde ich ist eine Kleinigkeit für die
Grünen aber die FDP hat sich nicht
durchgesetzt so wie es mir scheiße sie
würden
der entscheidenden Frage wird es neue
Brennstäbe geben die neuen brennt nicht
geben und solange wir diese neuen
brennen diese ganze Energie Problematik
die mit den Atomkraftwerken eine
Teillösung eine bescheidene kleine
Teillösung haben könnte nicht gelöst das
Problem ist nach wie vor vollständig
ungelöst liegt violent auf dem Tisch und
die Regierung ja wie hat sich in auf
einem Formel Kompromiss geeinigt wo die
FDP jetzt enttäuschender Weise
augenscheinlich dem zustimmen wird
eigentlich finde die FDP müsste das
Ablegen das ist viel zu wenig
was bedeutet das denn jetzt für die
Ökologie was bedeutet das für die
Wirtschaft in Deutschland diese sage ich
damit meinen Worten sie übersetzt diese
Weichei Entscheidung des Kanzlers die
viel zu wenig ist in ihren Augen die
bedeutet nach meinem Dafürhalten dass
man die eigentlichen Probleme noch nicht
erkannt hat du wirst eigentliche Problem
ist gar nicht die Tatsache dass wir im
Augenblick Schwierigkeiten mit der
Gasversorgung haben weil Russland einen
unzuverlässiger Lieferant ist und und
dass die Preise so sehr in die Höhe
gegangen sind sondern dass viel tiefer
liegende Problem ist dass noch viel
schlimmere Dinge auf uns zukommen können
ich meine wir haben diese Angriffe jetzt
gehabt auf die nordstream Leitungen wer
kann uns denn zusichern oder wer hat ein
Konzept für das mögliche Szenario das
andere erdgaspipelines die aus Norwegen
kommen die aus Aserbaidschan kommen die
aus Marokko kommen im Laufe des Winters
nicht möglicherweise auch solchen
Angriffen ausgesetzt sind und plötzlich
haben wir eine viel schlimmere
gasmangellage als das was diese famose
graspreiskommission zugrunde gelegt aber
die eigentlichen Probleme mit einer
weiteren Verschärfung der Lage rechnen
deshalb müssen wir nicht dass die
Regionen müssen wir umstellen bitte Herr
von Lucke
wir müssen umstellen und nicht nur über
Gas und Strom reden sondern auch über
erneuerbare Energien und wir können dir
das nicht alles immer weiter aufschieben
gerade in Krisen können wir eine
Veränderung
bleiben der rechnet mit Ihnen ab und er
sagt das ist heute nur Verschleierung
sie haben Sie Zeit gekauft es bringt
überhaupt nichts die Wirtschaft rockt
weiter runter und sie stehen im Frühjahr
der selben Entscheidung wieder ist
natürlich sehr verkürzt dargestellt denn
die Situation war ja im Frühjahr eine
völlig andere oder im Sommer ja da hat
Herr Habeck noch gesagt es gibt
überhaupt keine Verlängerung dann hat er
gesagt es gibt nur eine
notfallverlängerung also wenn gar nichts
anderes geht das ja nur sie lassen
ich lass mich überhaupt nicht feiern
sondern ich halte das für eine richtige
und staatspolitische Entscheidung die
jetzt getroffen wurde die man jetzt
erstmal positiv zur Kenntnis nehmen kann
und nicht weiter verlängert und nicht
erst mal nicht weiterfahren ich finde da
muss natürlich auch darüber sprechen wie
es im nächsten Winter weitergeht also
der jetzige Winter ist ja der Eine aber
warum sollen die Strompreise eigentlich
sinken die werden nicht sinken sondern
die werden auf dem Niveau bleiben und
deshalb muss es darum gehen alles
mögliche auch ins Netz zu nehmen da
gehören die Atomkraftwerke dazu da
gehören die Kohlekraftwerke dazu da
gehören aber auch die Braunkohle
waren Energien bitte bitte erneuerbar
aber wir brauchen nicht ganz in Abrede
stellen
Strom und das kriegen sie natürlich nur
mit Atomkraft mit Kern mit Kernkraft
also ich glaube nochmal eine wir waren
jetzt nicht dem kleinen wir waren schon
sehr sehr grundsätzlich und jeder
vielleicht verbuchen wir das jetzt mal
ist für die Erneuerbaren egal in welcher
Stärke im Norden er dem Wind in meiner
Heimat eher Wasserkraft und Regen also
Sonnenkraft und verbuchen wir dass es
jeder will wir brauchen auch den Umstieg
und diese Energiewende trotzdem brauchen
wir für die Leistungsfähigkeit unserer
Wirtschaft für das Bestehen des
deutschen Mittelstandes und die Quittung
war ja in Niedersachsen für die FDP mit
diesem Wahlergebnis das ist auch
Wirtschaften mit vielen Arbeitsplätzen
Frau engeling Käfer zu guten Löhnen
möglich weiterhin möglich ist in
Deutschland und ich kenne genug die
Arbeit einstellen weil sie sagen mit
diesen Strompreisen können wir nicht
mehr Wirtschaften die gehen frei nach
Harbeck nicht in die Insolvenz sondern
die hören einfach zum Arbeiten auf ob
das die Gärtnerei ist oder ein
siliziumwerk bei mir im Wahlkreis der
letzte deutsche siliziumhersteller der
regional auslieferdienst Chemiedreieck
das tut mir indem sie mit
Massenarbeitslosigkeit der Lücke
breche ich im Augenblick nicht ja wir
haben Arbeitskräftemangel in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland sind ganz
großes fundamentales Probleme haben aber
ich muss noch mal was zu den
erneuerbaren sagen erstens hat der
Scheffler schon zurecht gesagt es geht
ja auch um die grundlastfähigkeit und
die Erneuerbaren sind nicht
grundlastfähig aber wir dürfen auch die
das quantitative da nicht aus den Augen
verlieren die Erneuerbaren die wir jetzt
seit 15 Jahren 20 Jahren oder irgend
sowas ähnliches ausgebaut haben tragen
zur Zeit zum
Energiebedarf über unsere Deutschland 16
% 1
64%
84%, die sich unglaublich stark
verteuert haben und da kann man nicht
immer die Öffentlichkeit nass führen
indem man sagt ja wir machen jetzt die
Energiewende und dann brauchen wir diese
84% eigentlich nicht sondern wir blasen
unter 16 % irgendwie auch auf 100
herunterladen ja in dieser Zeit
überhaupt nicht wollen sie in dieser
Runde begrüßen sie sind von uns allen am
kürzesten in Deutschland bisher sie sind
vor ja 2015 zu uns gekommen aus Syrien
nach Deutschland wenn Sie all das
mitbekommen wenn sie auch im Moment
mitbekommen wo Deutschland gerade steht
haben Sie das Gefühl sie sind da in ein
Land gekommen was sich ja am Abgrund
befindet was gerade abstürzt abschmiert
also natürlich gibt es sehr viele
Probleme die schon spezifisches tauchen
natürlich wir kommen jetzt raus von dem
Corona Pandemie und dann kommt jetzt
noch mal der Krieg in der Ukraine das
bedeutet betrifft ja uns alle nicht nur
in der Ukraine und ich habe es natürlich
klarer Meinung dass das dass die
Menschen hier schon was tun können und
wir stehen auf die Seite der Ukraine wir
sind dabei bei der Unterstützung und
wenn ich höre wie viele Probleme gerade
darüber diskutiert wird ich mache mir
einfach Hoffnung dass wir das Handy
kriegen also vor dem Krieg in der
Ukraine wir haben natürlich erstes Mal
davon gehört dass in der Ukraine die
Menschen also erstmal wenn wir über
Flüchtlingspolitik natürlich also reden
die Menschen also Deutschland sagt ja
zwei Jahren also ein paar Monate vor dem
Krieg in der Ukraine der beginnen wir
haben ja keine Kapazität es ist mal
sprechen wir gleich drüber ganz kurz
noch einmal auch mit ihnen über das
Energiepreis Thema wie hoch ist aktuell
ihre Stromrechnung ihre Gasrechnung
macht Ihnen das zu schaffen zahlen Sie
dieselbe wird also übernommen ich
bezahle die selber kriege ich noch Bafög
aber das ist echt wenig mache mir
natürlich auch Sorge wie es wie ich mal
übers Winter mal drüber komme und ja im
Supermarkt ich kann viele Produkte mir
ich selber nicht mehr leisten zum
Beispiel ich kann mir nicht gesunde
ernähren wie früher ich habe immer so
vielleicht sag ich mal lachsfisch
gegessen und ich habe versucht mich
Gesundes zu ernähren heute ist
unbezahlbar dass ich ich werde das nicht
noch mal in meinem Kühlschrank
vielleicht wieder haben
genau das ist es nämlich nicht das hier
die Entlastungen nicht ausreichen für
die Menschen damit sie überhaupt über
die Runden kommen und da ist für mich
zum Beispiel ganz wichtig die Frage der
Gas und Strompreis Bremsen und die
Auseinandersetzungen die wir uns hier
leisten erst einmal mit dieser
gasumlage die ja katastrophal war was
ich auch herausgestellt hat wie viel
Zeit haben wir damit vertan und die
Menschen im Grunde genommen in die Irre
geschickt und jetzt die Frage der
gaspreisbremse was haben wir denn im
Dezember gibt es dann die Einmalzahlung
und die gasbremse soll es dann erst wenn
die Wintersaison vorbei ist das ist doch
nicht mehr nachvollziehbar
hört auch einen strombremse nicht nur
eine gaspreisbremse auch eine
Stromquelle gemacht um das jetzt schnell
auf die Straße zu bringen ja hätte man
jetzt erstmal
das gemacht was jetzt im Frühjahr gilt
das wäre gar nicht möglich gewesen sind
marktwirtschaftlich
ist das eigentlich die falsche Baustelle
also ich glaube man muss einfach das
Energieangebot erhöhen und so wir müssen
auf der anderen Seite auch versuchen
eine eine Fiskalpolitik zu betreiben und
eine Geldpolitik zu betreiben die
letztendlich die Inflation bekämpft was
den Finanzministerium
die Politik der EZB die ist seit 10 15
Jahren die Finanzminister und sagen
jetzt bei der Kritik von Frau engeling
liefern nein gut das machen wir jetzt
halt so weil es muss so schnell gehen
wir ja darauf dass wir den Laden auch
noch finanziell zusammenhalten denn
ja aber wenn es die FDP nicht gäbe dann
gibt es keine besser mehr genau das
wesentlich schlimmer grüner und SPD
hätten längst weil
wir reden über eine Politik das macht
ein bisschen Minuten weil der
Regierungsvertreter ich verstehe ja dass
sie jetzt nicht jeden grünen
Parteitagsbeschluss hier mit vertreten
können aber die Grundlinien ihrer
Politik verkaufen sie nach dem Motto
musste halt schnell gehen und dafür
hauen wir die Milliarden aus einzige der
einzige Euro Rebell ich glaube da waren
sie sich sehr nah in der Zeit der damals
das Geld zusammen nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein also Fakt ist schon das
jetzt die Hilfe schnell ankommen muss
200 Milliarden nein wofür und
Dimensionen wie ist die Zeitdimensionen
die Leute werden rebellisch zurecht denn
die müssen ja jede Woche oder jeden alle
paar Tage die hohen Rechnungen bezahlen
Abschläge die haben die Abschläge auf
dem Tisch liegen die wollen doch in
ihren Wohnungen bleiben und ähm
Finanzminister nicht die Orientierung am
hohen Erdgaspreis genau das ist der
Punkt
Milliarden zusammenhalten also das
müssen wir mal erklären die gesamten
Importe der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
an Öl und Gas im Jahre 2021 beliefen
sich auf 80 Milliarden Euro 80
Milliarden davon kam 40% aus Russland
das macht 32 Milliarden sie geben jetzt
200 Milliarden aus um diese 32
Milliarden die war letztes Jahr
ausgegeben haben zu verbilligen
irgendwie das geht für mich eben das
noch gar nicht also 200 Milliarden ist
200 Milliarden sollen dafür bewilligt
werden dass man diese gaspreisbremse
bekommt die ich im übrigen im Grundsatz
für richtig finde im Detail ist da
manchmal falsch aber grundsätzlich
richtig ja aber es sind 200 Milliarden
Euro für eine Menge an Importen die uns
im letzten Jahr 32 Euro
was ist denn daran die Milliarden
zusammenhalten ich meine das ist ein
Vielfaches von dem was wir letztes Jahr
ausgegeben haben was jetzt alles auf
Kosten des Steuerzahlers oder ist
künftigen Steuerzahler Verschuldung
finanziert werden wird finanzierbar alle
was wir jetzt machen ist dass wir den
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds einer
kreditermächtigung über 200 Milliarden
geben ob die dann am Ende genutzt werden
das wird man erst noch sehen müssen ja
das ist wie
bei den Retter
haben wir den Wirtschaft stabilisierungs
vor ja auch genutzt um Industrien zu
retten aber doch
also Stichwort Lufthansa Lufthansa hat
am Ende seine Hilfen wieder
zurückgezahlt ja also das heißt noch
nicht dass wir das tatsächlich in dieser
Form nutzen werden und dass wir das
dafür einsetzen werden es zu 100% zur
erdgasabsenkung zum Preis Absenkung
nutzen werden sondern dass ein
Instrument das uns jetzt durch diese
Krise führen soll das ist das Ziel ja
für die Menschen das wird man sehen das
hängt ein bisschen vom Verleiher das
heißt also
sagen ja aber wir sind doch jetzt in
einer Situation wo wir nur auf Sicht
fahren können wir haben den die
corona-situation wir haben Ukraine wir
wissen nicht wie der Krieg weiter
verläuft und es ist halt ein
gigantisches Paket dass sie dass sie da
unter den Weihnachtsbaum legen und am
Ende
Verantwortung Wörter auch dass man sage
ich mal im Blick auf diese Krise ein
bisschen auf Sicht fährt und jetzt nicht
ist schon alle Antworten parat hat wie
der wie der Krieg in der Ukraine
weitergeht das wissen wir doch heute
nicht welche Maßnahmen Herr Putin noch
ergreift um unsere Energie Situation
weiter ja damit können sie ja jede damit
können sie ja jede
Regierungsentscheidung begründen dass
man da sie einigen kann weil keine
Ahnung
diesen Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds
um uns darauf fortzubereiten das ist das
Ziel aber Herr Scheffler fahren Sie
nicht ein bisschen zu sehr auf sehr sehr
kurze Sicht also wenn ich das sehe dass
der Einmarsch in der Ukraine Ende
Februar erfolgreich
ja eine Woche am 23 September eine Woche
bevor die Heizperiode begann da hat die
Regierung plötzlich gesagt also und wenn
ich nicht mehr weiter weiß